hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr heute dabei seid ja
heute sind auf der US Militärbasis
Rammstein verschiedene Parteien der
Ukraine Kontaktgruppe zusammengekommen
um über weitere Unterstützung für die
Ukraine zu sprechen ja und der Elefant
im Raum der war bis gerade eben so ein
bisschen die Frage ob heute der Tag ist
an dem der neue Verteidigungsminister
Boris Pistorius auf die Aufforderung
anderer europäischer Bündnispartner
reagieren wird und einer Lieferung vom
Kampfpanzer Leopard in die Ukraine
zustimmt ja der Druck auf Deutschland
der Druck auf Olaf Scholz hat sich in
den letzten Tagen echt noch mal
verstärkt Großbritannien oder Polen
drängen auf einen zustimmen Deutschlands
doch seit eben Boris Pistorius in
Rammstein vor die Presse getreten ist
ist erst einmal klar Deutschland sendet
vorerst keine Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine
ja was das für die Rammstein Konferenz
aber auch für den russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine bedeutet
darüber wollen wir heute sprechen und
diskutieren und zwar zum einen mit live
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Christiane
hübscher und mit dem militärökonom
Markus Kolb und natürlich wie immer hier
bei ZDF heute live auch mit euch da
draußen deswegen wenn ihr Fragen an die
beiden habt oder einfach eure Meinung
eure Fragen eure Kommentare Anregungen
zum Thema mit uns hier teilen wollt dann
schreibt uns gerne im Youtube Chat oder
per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de jetzt schauen wir uns
aber erstmal gemeinsam das Statement an
dass der Verteidigungsminister Beruf
Pistorius heute kurz vor 14 Uhr in
Ramstein gegeben hat
und in der Tat haben wir auch über die
Lieferung von Mücke die mögliche
Lieferung von Leopard Panzern natürlich
gesprochen
und zum einen muss ich feststellen ganz
eindeutig es gibt kein einheitliches
Meinungsbild
der Eindruck der gelegentlich entstanden
ist es gebe eine geschlossene Koalition
und deutschland stehe im Weg dieser
Eindruck ist falsch
es gibt viele alliierte viele Verbündete
die sagen wir teilen die Auffassung die
ich heute dich auch noch mal da gelegt
habe es gibt gute Gründe für die
Lieferung des gute Gründe dagegen
und angesichts der Gesamtsituation eines
Krieges der jetzt schon fast ein Jahr
dauert sind alle Pro und Contras sehr
sorgfältig abzuwägen
und diese Einschätzung wird von vielen
Alliierten das ist sehr deutlich
geworden in den Gesprächen ausdrücklich
geteilt es gibt aber auch natürlich die
anderen
wir können alle heute noch nicht sagen
wann eine Entscheidung und wie die
Entscheidung aussehen wird zu Leopard
Panzer ich jedenfalls nicht die wissen
warum
ich war aber in meinem beruflichen Leben
einer Erfahrung gemacht wenn man nicht
weiß wann eine Entscheidung kommt und
wie sie aussieht sollte man versuchen
vor der Lage zu sein
da spricht dann auch der Innenminister
der langjährige und vor der Lage zu sein
heißt für mich ich möchte dann wenn
einer Entscheidung fällt ob in einer
Woche oder in zwei oder in einem Tag
gerne in der Lage sein auch schnell
handeln zu können für den Fall an der
negativen Entscheidung ist nicht zu tun
für den Fall einer positiven muss es
dann aber schnell gehen weil es dann
darum geht auszubilden die Leopard
Panzer zu überprüfen und dergleichen
mehr deswegen habe ich heute morgen
meinem Haus den Auftrag erteilt eine
Prüfung vorzunehmen über die Bestände
von Leopard Panzern der verschiedenen
Typen sowohl in unseren eigenen
Streitkräften als auch bei der Industrie
und wir werden dabei insbesondere ins
Auge nehmen die Frage der Kompatibilität
der Systeme auch mit denen unserer
Partner die Verfügbarkeit und die
Stückzahl das alles ist kein priodids
das ist schlicht und ergreifend
Vorbereitung auf einen Tag der kommen
möglicherweise kommen mag dann wären wir
sofort handlungsfähig und könnten
innerhalb kürzester Zeit die
Unterstützung liefern wenn denn diese
Entscheidung zwischen der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und den transatlantischen
Partnern und den NATO-Partnern insgesamt
so getroffen wird das ist jetzt eine
Frage die ich nicht beantworten kann
aber wir sind vorbereitet wir bereiten
uns vor für den Fall der Fälle das
wollte ich sie wissen lassen vielen Dank
ja soweit zu Boris Pistorius und einem
verlautbaren einer vs nicht-entscheidung
und hier ist schon Christiane schön dass
du bei uns bist hallo ich bin ihr Fragen
an Christiane habt dann schreibt die
gerne hier in den Chat oder per Mail an
ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de
Christiane jetzt ist ja diese Meldung
noch gar nicht so alt gibt es denn schon
Reaktionen aus dem politischen Berlin
also ich habe noch keine gesehen ich
habe gerade eben noch mal die Agenturen
und mein Twitter gecheckt ich konnte da
nichts entdecken was wahrscheinlich
daran liegt dass alle Journalisten aber
auch Ampel Politiker aber auch die
Opposition offensichtlich so ein
bisschen überrascht sind weil wir hatten
ja doch tatsächlich alle heute sehr
hingefiebert vielleicht kann man sagen
also hingearbeitet auf dieses Rammstein
treffen viele haben sich davon eine
Entscheidung in die eine oder in die
andere Richtung was die Leopard zwei
Panzer betrifft erhofft die hat es jetzt
nicht gegeben
hat im Grunde genommen gesagt wir haben
uns vertagt wir haben nichts entschieden
man kann es auch anders lesen man kann
sagen die Bundesregierung bleibt hart
Kanzler Scholz bleibt hart oder bleibt
bei seiner Linie kann man auch sagen
damit Boris Pistole ist nicht ganz so
ohnmächtig vor den Kameras Stand hat er
sich wahrscheinlich überlegt was sage
ich ich gebe zumindest mal einen
Prüfauftrag raus wir zählen schon mal
durch was wir in der in der Industrie
und in der Truppe an Leopard 2
Kampfpanzern haben
wenn man was liefern würde würde das
sowieso aus aus den Beständen der
Industrie kommen und er hat also heute
morgen hat er ja gerade gesagt den
Auftrag gegeben einmal zu prüfen wie
viele man davon überhaupt vorrätig hat
und in welchem Zustand die sind und wie
schnell die im Zweifel rausgegeben
werden könnte das macht er um im Grunde
so ein bisschen Handlungsfähigkeit zu
demonstrieren und zu sagen es ist nicht
so dass ich nichts tun sondern wenn die
Entscheidung kommt und es kann ja
irgendwann in den nächsten Tagen sein
und sie sollte so sein dass Deutschland
doch Kampf Fanta liefert dann will ich
zumindest wissen was habe ich auf dem
Hof stehen was könnte ich schicken
ja du sprichst gerade von diesem
Prüfauftrag den Pistorius verkündet hat
da kommt bei mir sofort die Frage und
auch bei einigen aus der Community da
schreibt zum Beispiel Timo altenwerth
auf Youtube Bestände aufnehmen hätte man
auch schon vor Monaten machen können und
das ist auch die Frage die ich mir
automatisch Stelle dieses Thema ist ja
nicht erst seit heute morgen auf dem
Tisch warum fängt man denn jetzt an die
Bestände zu überprüfen das ist richtig
diese Frage stellen viele jetzt die ist
auch gerade Boris Pistorius gestellt
worden in diesem Pressestatement gab es
ja danach noch so einen kleinen
Fragezeichen
also er hat nicht mit dem Finger auf
Christine Lambrecht gezeigt aber letzten
Endes ist es natürlich so sie hat das
nicht prüfen lassen sie hat einfach
abgewartet auf eine Entscheidung die da
kommt natürlich könnte man das so machen
natürlich könnte man vorher schon mal
schauen was ist da Pistorius hat jetzt
gerade in dem Statement gesagt er geht
davon aus dass ein Haus wie das seine
dass er ja nun erst seit 24 Stunden
kennt und dem auch vorsteht längst
Überblick hat was da da ist aber er hat
heute morgen eben erst hat sich damit
entschuldigt dass er ja erst vor kurzem
Amt ist den Prüfauftrag wirklich
ausgeben können aber ja diese Frage kann
man stellen warum ist das nicht längst
passiert warum weiß man das nicht
ja du hast eben auch angesprochen dass
ja alle so ein bisschen auch auf diesen
Tag hingefiebert haben viele haben
gedacht heute kommt die Entscheidung
dieses Statement von Pistorius zeigt er
jetzt eigentlich auch das Scholz sich
dem Druck der letzten Tage dieser
letzten Woche offenbar erstmal nicht
beugt oder das kann man so sagen also
Scholz bleibt bei seiner Linie Pistorius
hatte ja jetzt die die Aufgabe das dann
zu erläutern und er hat sich dafür
entschieden zu sagen wir sind da gar
nicht alleine also er hat gesagt der
Eindruck dass Deutschland da irgendwie
der Bremse sei der blockiere sei den
anderen im Weg stehen würde also alle
würden Panzer liefern wollen ähm in
Europa außer Deutschland das stimmig
man würde dann natürlich an der Stelle
immer gerne wissen wer ist denn noch bei
uns also wer unterstützt denn unseren
Kurs das hat er nicht gesagt wir wissen
dass es neuen Staaten in Europa gibt die
gerne Kampfpanzer deutscher Produktion
diesen Leopard 2 liefern würden
allerdings brauchen die natürlich eine
Ausfuhr Genehmigung
von Deutschland ebenfalls was Panzer
deutscher Produktion sind Pistorius hat
auf Nachfrage dann gesagt da sei bis
heute auch zum Beispiel von Polen die
das hier angekündigt haben sich auch
darüber hinwegzusetzen über so eine über
so eine Ausfuhrgenehmigung und es
einfach zu machen
sei bis heute keine keinen Antrag
eingegangen
Pistorius hat er eben auch davon
gesprochen diese Entscheidung könnte
zwei Wochen dauern sie könnte eine Woche
dauern sie könnte aber auch einen Tag
dauern wie schätzt du denn das ein jetzt
ist ja am Sonntag Scholz auch bei macron
in Frankreich dass das Treffen des
deutsch-französischen Ministerrat ist
das vielleicht noch ein Termin bei dem
er diese Entscheidung verkünden könnte
absolut das sehe ich auch so oder
zumindest könnte man sagen das ist jetzt
die der nächste Termin auf den wir alle
schauen ähm der letzten Endes ist es
natürlich eine Aufgabe des
Bundeskanzlers von Olaf Scholz so eine
Entscheidung der weitreichend wäre ähm
bekannt zu geben und tatsächlich
erreicht am Sonntag nach Paris trifft
sich damit macron zum Anlass sind die
sind 60 Jahre Elysee Vertrag und ein
deutsch-französischer Ministerrat und da
gibt's natürlich eine Pressekonferenz
und womöglich gibt es dann da die
Entscheidung das wäre also in zwei Tagen
es kann aber auch länger dauern es kann
auch schneller gehen man kann auch mal
ganz schnell in Berlin vorne von der
Presse treten sollte es eine
Entscheidung geben aber
nichts Genaues weiß man nicht
danke dir Christine für diese ganze
frischen Eindrücke aus Berlin gerne
ja und wie gesagt heute ist dieses
Treffen der Ukraine Kontaktgruppe in
Ramstein lasst uns da noch mal kurz
reingucken was heute schon besprochen
würde und was passiert ist bis jetzt das
hat sich Florian neuhahn für uns
angeguckt
minutenlang steht Boris Pistorius am
Morgen auf dem Parkplatz vor dem
US-amerikanischen Militärstützpunkt in
Ramstein Rheinland-Pfalz und telefoniert
letzte Abstimmungen zur Frage die hier
alle interessiert die Lieferung von
Leopard zweikampfpanzern wer weiß vor
den Kameras zunächst keine Äußerung es
ist der Gastgeber
US-Verteidigungsminister Leuten der neue
Hilfen ankündigt in Höhe von 2,5
Milliarden US-Dollar
das zeigt die USA bleiben entschlossen
zu führen und der Ukraine bei der
Selbstverteidigung zu helfen
im neuen Paket enthalten Bradley
Kampffahrzeuge und gepanzerte
Mannschaftstransporter vom Typ Striker
aber keine Kampfpanzer die in Ramstein
der ukrainische Präsident per
Videobotschaft fordert es steht in ihrer
Macht aus Rammstein heraus Panzer zu
senden nicht zu falschen über die Anzahl
sondern sich grundsätzlich für diese
Lieferung zu öffnen um das Böse aus
Russland zu stoppen
es ist natürlich eine Botschaft an dem
Zuhörenden deutschen Minister an das
Land das zuletzt auch von Verbündeten
immer stärker unter Druck gesetzt wurde
etwa aus Großbritannien das als erster
nato-staat eigene Challenger zu
Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine schicken will
oder aus Polen dessen Regierung zuletzt
sogar androte seine Leopard Panzer
notfalls auch ohne die nötige deutsche
Zustimmung zu liefern vor wenigen
Minuten dann tritt Boris Pistorius vor
die Kameras zu der Frage die hier alle
interessiert
wir können alle heute noch nicht sagen
wann eine Entscheidung und wie sie
Entscheidung aussehen wird zu Leopard
Panzer ich jedenfalls nicht die wissen
warum
ich war aber in meinem beruflichen Leben
einer Erfahrung gemacht wenn man nicht
weiß wann eine Entscheidung kommt und
wie sie aussieht sollte man versuchen
vor der Lage zu sein heißt man werde
sich vorbereiten auf eine mögliche
Lieferung von Leopard Panzern aber noch
nicht liefern die Spannung in dieser
Frage also bleibt
ja und ich bin hier verbunden jetzt mit
militärökonom Markus schön dass Sie bei
uns sind hallo
ich habe mir eben sagen lassen dass als
das Statement von Herrn Pistorius lief
sie energisch mit dem Kopf geschüttelt
haben deswegen frage ich sie gleich mal
wie ist denn ihre Reaktion auf dieses
Statement
ja es ist eine Mischung aus Bankrott
Erklärung und sich verstecken hinter
sogenannten anderen die das auch
kritisch sehen da musste ich dran denken
es ist so als wenn der Student sagt ich
bin leider durchgefallen durch die
Prüfung aber fünf andere auch und
deswegen bin ich ja eigentlich gar nicht
so schlecht also wissen Sie wenn Sie
sich als Verteidigungsminister
hinstellen und sagen sie geben jetzt
einen sogenannten Prüfauftrag um erstmal
durchzuzählen wie viel Waffensysteme
haben sie überhaupt und in welchem
einsatzfähigen Zustand sind die das ist
ja eine völlige bankrot Erklärung sowas
müssten sie per sofort wissen das ist
militärisches grundhandwerk
vielleicht ist das jetzt die nächste
Ausrede dass man sagt ja ja also im
Prinzip wären wir jetzt politisch sogar
bereit die zu liefern nur leider leider
ist das alles nicht einsatzfähig denn es
ist wirklich nur noch beschämend man
kann es nicht anders sagen also für eine
Nationen die ja Phase von
Führungsanspruch und Verantwortung für
Europa und so weiter es ist wirklich
ich kann es nicht anders ausdrücken
ja da schließt sich auch schon so ein
bisschen eine Frage aus der Community an
da fragt nämlich Sven Odendahl auf
Facebook
warum ist diese Prüfung nicht schon
vorgenommen und hat die Bundeswehr auch
bei anderen Beständen keinen genauen
Überblick über den Bestand und was sagt
das über die Bundeswehr aus ich denke
das haben sie eben gerade schon ganz gut
zusammengefasst was glauben Sie denn wie
reagieren gerade in Rammstein die
Bündnispartner auf dieses Statement
wissen Sie ich sage jetzt nach bald
einem Jahr Krieg immer man hat das ganze
Jahr 2022 eigentlich vertan mit
theoretischen Diskussionen was alles
nicht geht also wir erinnern uns
vielleicht noch Februar März ne also es
ist von diversen Beratung selbst
genannten Experten Ukraine kann nicht
gewinnen dann hat man gesagt ja Ukraine
kann vielleicht ein bisschen durchhalten
aber die westlichen Waffensysteme können
sie nicht bedienen und die schweren
schon gar nicht und so weiter und so
weiter fast ein Jahr lang hat man jetzt
vertan mit Diskussionen ähm was unter
anderem dazu geführt hat dass viele
Soldaten und Zivilisten deswegen
gestorben sind der Krieg könnte längst
eine andere Wendung genommen haben
könnte vielleicht sogar schon vorbei
sein wenn man sich früher entschlossen
hätte und jetzt versteckt man sich
hinter diesen sogenannten anderen ich
möchte die Frage zurückgeben also das
soll Herr Pistorius doch bitte klar
sagen wer das ist also die einzige
Nation die ich mir vorstellen könnte
wäre Belgien weil die haben relativ
passiven Ansatz bisher aber wissen Sie
es gibt so viele Nationen die
bereits verkündet haben sie haben es ja
selber gesagt Polen Großbritannien aber
auch die skandinavischen Länder die
baltischen Länder die Niederlande die
heute sogar gesagt haben wir erwägen
sogar F16 Kampfflugzeuge bereits in die
Ukraine zu schicken also ihm zu
zusätzlich zu panzern und wenn sie jetzt
sagen es gibt keine Einigkeit ja bitte
dann soll er die zwei oder drei oder
vier nennen die das nicht wollen aber
auch das wie gesagt es ist ein
verstecken hinter anderen was was hat es
für eine Bedeutung dass zwei drei oder
vier nicht mitmachen wollen dann sollen
sich sein lassen aber das würde
Deutschland nicht daran hindern seine
Kampfpanzer zu liefern es sind
vorgeschobene Argumente
ich werfe gerade mal einen Blick in den
Chat und sehe das Ganze viele von euch
nach den Reaktionen aus der Ukraine
fragen da sie vielleicht interessant für
euch zu wissen dass wir hier gleich noch
über die ukrainische Perspektive
sprechen werden nämlich mit dem
ukrainischen Vize-Außenminister andre
Melnik Herr Kolb für sie ist aber auch
eine Frage im Chat und zwar fragt alles
auf Youtube der Militärexperte letztes
Mal meinte spielt ja wahrscheinlich auf
unsere Sendung an die Panzer würden
keine militärische Entscheidung bringen
wieso sollten wir uns dann weiter in
Richtung Eskalation durch die Lieferung
bewegen
würden keine Entscheidung bringen da da
würde ich gerne wissen wer dieser
sogenannte Militärexperte war aber um es
um es mal klar zu sagen die Entscheidung
die muss die Ukraine jetzt suchen in der
Frühjahrsoffensive und es ist wichtig
dass die Lieferung schwerer
Waffensysteme insbesondere Panzer jetzt
passiert damit sie die Logistik
vorbereiten können damit sie eine
ausgewiesene einsatzkette haben also
sprich was die Treibstoffe Ersatzteile
und so weiter angeht dass sie dann
diesen Vorstoß führen können
selbstverständlich wird das Wirkung im
Einsatzraum erzielen und schwere mobile
Mittel sind genau das was die Ukraine
braucht und die russische Front an ihrer
schwächsten Stelle
zu durchstoßen also wissen Sie ich ich
bin jetzt nach bald einem Krieg einem
Jahr Krieg leid immer wieder diesen
Unsinn anzuhören es geht nicht man kann
nicht und es hat sowieso keinen Zweck
selbstverständlich hat das Sinn und
Wirkung es ist vielleicht nur so dass
wir nach 20 Jahren russischer Propaganda
so durch solche sind von diesem Gedanken
es geht nicht und kann nicht dass man
das gar nicht mehr hinterfragt
ja sie sagen es gerade wir sprechen hier
schon sehr lange über Krieg und seit
einigen Wochen und Monaten ja auch
vermehrt über verschiedene Panzer und
Panzertypen und was die im Kampfeinsatz
zu Folge haben das ist manchmal gar
nicht so einfach zu verstehen und
deswegen hat uns das Dominik lesmeister
mal zusammengefasst
der Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 ist stark
gepanzert wiegt über 60 Tonnen und hat
1500 PS er hat eine leistungsfähige 120
mm Grad rohrkanone ihre Aufgabe andere
Panzer und Fahrzeuge beschießen oder
zerstören oder der Infanterie durch
Beschuss von Häusern und Stellungen
helfen dabei werden die Kampfpanzer von
Panzergrenadieren mit Schützenpanzern
unterstützt
Schützenpanzer wie der Marder sind
gepanzerte Transportfahrzeuge für
Infanterie Soldaten sie sind beweglich
nicht so schwer wie Kampfpanzer und
haben eine leichtere Kanone bei Marder
eine 20 mm Bordkanone ihre Aufgabe
Soldaten schnell und geschützt im
Gelände absetzen zur Besatzung können
Sie sechs weitere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten aufnehmen feindliche Infanterie
und deren gepanzerte Kampf Fahrzeuge
bekämpfen gemeinsam mit den Kampfpanzern
halten Sie die Bewegung und Stoßkraft
der Panzertruppen aufrecht im Verbund
entfalten Schütz lufthan Samara und
Kampfpanzer Leopard ihre größte
Wirksamkeit
das vielleicht mal als Übersicht warum
es welcher Panzer da im Verbund kämpft
wir haben noch eine Frage aus dem
youtube-chat und zwar von icke wie stark
ist der internationale Ruf Deutschlands
durch Scholz zögern jetzt ihrer versibel
geschädigt was ist da ihre Einschätzung
ja also die hochschädigung die ist
bereits eingetreten also ich folge zum
Beispiel in den polnischen und den
baltischen Diskussionen relativ eng und
wenn jetzt zum Beispiel der polnische
Premiere oder jetzt die sich hinstellt
und sagt also wenn ihr noch lange so
weitermacht dann werden wir einfach in
die Initiative gehen und das halte ich
für durchaus realistisch es gab ja
gestern den sogenannten Talent Pletsch
also wie soll ich sagen eine Koalition
von Ländern die sagen wir sind Willens
Kampfpanzer zu liefern und weitere
schwere Waffensysteme und ich kann mir
durchaus vorstellen dass irgendwann die
Frustration über die deutsche Politik so
groß sein wird dass man sagt okay dann
machen wir es jetzt einfach auf eigene
Faust also sprich das Rammstein Format
ist ja ein Gesamt nato-format also wenn
das beschlossen wird dann stehen alle
NATO Partner dahinter es ist aber
durchaus möglich dass ich jetzt so
sozusagen eine fast vorbildgruppe bildet
also von Nationen die sagen wir gehen
jetzt einfach rein und was die Deutschen
machen das ist deutsche Innenpolitik das
interessiert uns gar nicht mehr
wir hatten hier in der Sendung auch
schon den Militärexperten und oberstad
Wolfgang Richter da und da habe ich hier
ein Zitat was ich ihnen gerne mal
vorlesen würde weil mich da ihre
Reaktion interessieren würde der hat
nämlich gesagt es ist selbstverständlich
klar dass Deutschland nicht im
Alleingang etwas tut deswegen wird es
immer aus deutscher Sicht wichtig sein
dass der hauptverbündete USA mit an Bord
ist es hilft ja nichts wenn eine Flotte
von Leopard Panzern in der Ukraine
erscheint die dann ja nach wie vor ein
deutsches System darstellen und dieses
deutsche System wird ja auch durch
Deutschland genehmigt werden müssen
selbst wenn es andere Armeen im Einsatz
oder im Bestand haben deswegen kommt es
darauf an dass zumindest die Briten
Franzosen und Amerikaner mit an Bord
sind also wirklich im Verbund agieren
was sagen sie dazu
ja das ist es ist genau das gleiche
Argument man versteckt sich hinter
hinter dem Scheinargument naja wir
können nicht liefern bevor die anderen
es nicht tun ich denke er vermischt da
zwei Dinge die nicht zusammengehören das
eine ist das Gefechte verbundenen Waffen
also sprich der Panzer operiert
natürlich nicht alleine wie wir es in
ihrem Beitrag auch gesehen haben der
infa operiert natürlich in
Zusammenarbeit mit Infanterie mit
gepanzerten leichteren Fahrzeugen wie
dem Marder und so weiter aber
selbstverständlich hindert das
Deutschland nicht daran irgendwelche
Systeme zu liefern es es führt dann
wieder auf ein anderes vorgeschobenes
Argument nach dem Motto die Ukraine
könnten das nicht bedienen also wissen
Sie wenn ich angucke wie Großbritannien
die ukrainischen Crews ausgebildet hat
und die innerhalb von Tagen die
westlichen Waffensysteme beherrschen
beim deutschen Gepard hat man sehr
gesehen bei der Luftabwehr
kann ich mir das nicht wirklich
vorstellen ich weiß nicht warum er sowas
sagt aber
das sind alles so politische
Scheinargumente aber die militärische
Logik die ist eine andere die
militärische Logik heißt
Frühjahrsoffensive und für die
Frühjahrsoffensive sind die Mittel von
Nöten ich glaube es ist vor allem in
Deutschland so ein gewisses Generationen
Problem dass es viele wirklich Probleme
haben sich von diesen Illusionen der
1970er Jahre zu lösen von dieser immer
noch sehr starken Russland Affinität von
diesem Unwillen zuzugeben dass wir es
hier mit einem aggressiven Imperium zu
tun haben mit dem so etwas wie
Sicherheit oder Völkerrecht eben nicht
machbar ist oder zumindest nicht mehr
seit Putin ähm diese Diskussion die
führen uns nirgendwohin was die Ukraine
braucht ist die Fähigkeit die russische
Aggression zurückzuwerfen und diese
Fähigkeit erlangt nur indem Sie die
entsprechenden schweren Mittel bekommt
alles andere sind politische scheinen
Argument
lassen sie uns nochmal auf Frankreich
und auf die USA gucken jetzt ist ja
heute Nacht glaube ich bekannt geworden
dass die USA ein weiteres Waffen Pakete
geschnürt haben da wird gesprochen von
Strikern von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen
Kampfpanzer sendet die USA aber nach wie
vor nicht und auch die Franzosen sind ja
offenbar so ein bisschen zurückhaltend
Panzern oder
ja also macron hat hat ja auch in der
Vergangenheit so gewisse Probleme gehabt
sich von seiner Russland Affinität zu
lösen aber es ist ihm eigentlich sehr
viel besser gelungen als stolz also wenn
Sie schauen frankreich hat ja bereits
z.B schwere artillerie-systeme wie die
ca Kanone geliefert und mit dem AFX auch
bereits sogenannte leichte Panzer also
gepanzerte Radfahrzeuge und ich kann mir
durchaus vorstellen dass Frankreich da
weitermachen könnte und irgendwann auch
geklärt Panzer liefert ich denke sie
werden nicht die Ersten sein also diese
diese Fast Forward Koalition von der ich
vorhin gesprochen habe die wird
wahrscheinlich von Großbritannien und
Polen ange wird werden und wenn
Großbritannien dann schwere Panzer
liefert dann würde ich sagen also so wie
ich Frankreich einschätze aus Prestige
Gründen müsste macron dann gleich ziehen
weil er kann sich da natürlich nicht vom
perfid Albion dann vorführen lassen ich
mache ich scherze jetzt ein bisschen
aber naja ich denke wir müssen das ganze
realistisch sehen auf auf sogenannte
exportgenehmigungen wird es wenn wenn
das noch ein paar Wochen so weitergeht
gar nicht mehr ankommen wissen sie der
Pistorius hat sich jetzt hingestellt und
sagt wenn die Entscheidung dann fällt in
einem Tag oder eine Woche ja klar ich
meine die Entscheidung kann auch erst in
einem Jahr fallen dann haben Sie noch
ein Jahr Zeit die Leos durchzuzählen
aber das hilft ihm nicht weiter und ich
glaube über die nächsten Wochen wird die
militärische Realität stärker gewichtet
werden als die politische und vielleicht
führt das dann dazu dass man sagt okay
ob jetzt der gestempelte formelle Antrag
aus Polen da ist oder ob es noch
irgendwelche exportgenehmigungen Bedarf
darauf kommt es gar nicht mehr an wer
liefern kann der wird
wir haben hier noch eine Frage aus der
Community an sie nämlich von Susan auf
Youtube die hat vielleicht eine
organisatorische Frage weil sie fragt
sich die Soldaten zumindest am Panzer
ausbilden könnte man doch eigentlich
schon oder
ja selbstverständlich es gibt auch
Nationen die das schon längst tun also
die ukrainische Soldaten quasi in Irland
holen und sie dort ausbilden das beste
Beispiel ist Großbritannien dass das
seit Monaten nicht nur an verschiedenen
Waffensystemen macht sondern auch zum
Beispiel in der infanteristischen Taktik
und man könnte das genauso weiterführen
also sagen wir holen jetzt die
ukrainischen und bilden sie an der
westlichen Waffensystem aus und das ist
weniger kompliziert als viele jetzt
vielleicht denken also wenn sie mal
gelernt haben
taktisch in einem Panzer zu kämpfen und
Panzer zu fahren dann können sie sich
relativ leicht umschulen auf andere
Systeme das hat man ja immer so der
Ukraine vorgehalten ja ihr könnt das
nicht oder die Systeme sind so
kompliziert oder ihr könnt die
lateinische Schrift nicht lesen und was
ist noch an absurden Argumenten alles
gab und sie sehen wie die Ukraine sehr
innovativ und auch sehr schnell diese
Waffensysteme herrschen also da mache
ich mir keine Sorgen nein ich denke auch
das ist ein ein sinnvoller Weg weil es
geht ja nicht nur um die Panzer sondern
großes System bringt ja eine ganze Kette
von Logistik von Support von Treibstoff
mit sich und die idealen Räume diese zu
organisieren das wären eben die die nah
an der Ukraine sind also idealerweise
Polen Rumänien Slowakei und wenn man das
zusammen nimmt also spricht man bildet
die die Crews aus und verlegt die
Logistik in Front nahe Bereiche dann
erzielt man auch in großen einsatzwerten
ja hier flattern die Fragen an Sie haben
gerade nur so rein ich ähm übermittle
Ihnen die jetzt noch mal und hier fragt
auf Youtube Coach Charlie Herr Kolb was
kann man noch tun um der russischen
Rüstungsindustrie das Genick zu brechen
ja so da muss ich ein bisschen kaltes
Wasser aus diesen also dass das Genick
brechen werden sie ihr nicht dass aus
dem einfachen Grund dass die Rüst
russische Rüstungsindustrie also sofern
wir über die einfachen Kampfmittel
sprechen weitgehend autark funktioniert
das ist nicht so bei den Exportgütern
bei bei Kampfflugzeugen und so weiter
aber wenn wir jetzt schauen ähm
russische T-72 also die
Technologieplattform wenn Sie schauen
Artillerie Granaten und so weiter das
können die Russen weitgehend
selbstständig herstellen natürlich jetzt
nicht besonders effizient auch nicht im
in größeren Stückzahlen und auch die
Reserven gehen zu neige aber Russland
wird schon weiter produzieren das heißt
es kommt nicht so sehr darauf an die
russische Produktion jetzt einzustellen
weil das können sie gar nicht sondern es
kommt darauf an die westliche Position
zu steigern und vor allem die Ukraine
auf das westliche technologieniveau zu
bringen das ist übrigens auch die Idee
hinter dem Panzer Lieferungen also der
britische Challenger 2 ist auf ein
weitaus höheren technologienniveau als
der russische T-72 und kann den auch
sehr sehr böse abschießen das haben wir
zuletzt 2003 gesehen im Irakkrieg das
halte ich für ein produktiveren weg
und eine Frage habe ich noch zum Schluss
für sehr Kolb jetzt wie fragt auf
Youtube was würde denn ihrer Meinung
nach passieren wenn die Russen die
früher als Offensive zurückschlagen und
die Front sich wieder einpendelt liefern
wir dann mehr und mehr
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wie
sieht das wie sie das tun wollen weil
bei den jetzigen verlustquoten sowohl an
schweren Mitteln wie auch an Artillerie
sie müssen ja denken die russische
feuerfrequenz ist gesunken von 30.000
Artillerie Granaten noch jetzt noch 6000
Tendenzen ja also Russland kommt so
langsam ans Ende seiner Reserven
die die der Fall ist viel mehr umgekehrt
also was passiert eigentlich brauchen
ähm ist die Möglichkeit dieses Momentum
auszunutzen also sprich das Momentum wo
die die russischen Reserven langsam so
Neige gehen und dann diesen Vorstoß mit
neuem massierten Material durchzuführen
und damit Russland zu zwingen zuzugeben
dass es nicht auf die gleiche
Produktionsquote kommen kann und dann
kommt tatsächlich der Rollback also die
Rückabwicklung der Front und wenn sie
jetzt sagen Russland müsste das
zurückwerfen dann müsste Russland in der
Lage sein nicht nur mehr als alle
westlichen Nationen zu liefern sondern
auch schneller und bei meiner Kenntnis
der russischen Zustände kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen wie das der Fall sein
sollte
ja vielen Dank für Ihre Antworten danke
dass Sie meine und die Fragen der
Community beantwortet haben wie das
weitergeht wir bleiben auf jeden Fall
dran ich bin mir sicher wir werden zu
dem Thema auch noch mal sprechen vielen
Dank
ja und wir gucken jetzt noch mal in das
Statement was Verteidigungsminister
Boris pistorias heute in Ramstein
abgegeben hat
und in der Tat haben wir auch über die
Lieferung von Mücke die mögliche
Lieferung von Leopard Panzern natürlich
gesprochen
und zum einen muss ich feststellen ganz
eindeutig es gibt kein einheitliches
Meinungsbild
der Eindruck der gelegentlich entstanden
ist es gebe eine geschlossene Koalition
und deutschland stehe im Weg dieser
Eindruck ist falsch
es gibt viele alliierte viele Verbündete
die sagen wir teilen die Auffassung die
ich häufig auch noch mal dargelegt habe
es gibt gute Gründe für die Lieferung
das gute Gründe dagegen
und angesichts der Gesamtsituation eines
Krieges der jetzt schon fast ein Jahr
dauert sind alle Pro und Contras sehr
sorgfältig abzuwägen
und diese Einschätzung wird von vielen
Alliierten das ist sehr deutlich
geworden in den Gesprächen ausdrücklich
geteilt es gibt aber auch natürlich die
anderen
wir können alle heute noch nicht sagen
wann eine Entscheidung und wie die
Entscheidung aussehen wird zu Leopard
tanzen ich jedenfalls nicht die wissen
warum
ich war aber in meinem beruflichen Leben
einer Erfahrung gemacht wenn man nicht
weiß wann eine Entscheidung kommt und
wie sie aussieht sollte man versuchen
vor der Lage zu sein
da spricht dann auch der Innenminister
der langjährige und vor der Lage zu sein
heißt für mich ich möchte dann wenn
einer Entscheidung fällt ob in einer
Woche oder in zwei oder in einem Tag
gerne in der Lage sein auch schnell
handeln zu können für den Fall an der
negativen Entscheidung ist nicht zu tun
für den Fall einer positiven muss es
dann aber schnell gehen weil es dann
darum geht auszubilden die Leopard
Panzer zu überprüfen und dergleichen
mehr deswegen habe ich heute morgen
meinem Haus den Auftrag erteilt eine
Prüfung vorzunehmen über die Bestände
von Leopard Panzern der verschiedenen
Typen sowohl in unseren eigenen
Streitkräften als auch bei der Industrie
und wir werden dabei insbesondere ins
Auge nehmen die Frage der Kompatibilität
der Systeme auch mit denen unserer
Partner die Verfügbarkeit und die
Stückzahl das alles ist kein priodids
das ist schlicht und ergreifend
Vorbereitung auf einen Tag der kommen
möglicherweise kommen mag dann wären wir
sofort handlungsfähig und könnten
innerhalb kürzester Zeit die
Unterstützung liefern wenn denn diese
Entscheidung zwischen der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und den transatlantischen
Partnern und den NATO-Partnern insgesamt
so getroffen wird das ist jetzt eine
Frage die ich nicht beantworten kann
aber wir sind vorbereitet wir bereiten
uns vor für den Fall der Fälle das
wollte ich sie wissen lassen vielen Dank
ja und über dieses Statement wollen wir
sprechen mit dem Ex-Botschafter der
Ukraine in Deutschland und jetzigen
Vize-Außenminister der Ukraine André
Mähne hallo Herr Melnik schön dass Sie
bei uns sind
schon guten Tag
ja wir haben eben noch mal einen Blick
auf dieses Statement des neuen
Verteidigungsministers Boris Pistorius
geworfen Herr Melnik was ist ihre erste
Reaktion auf diese Entscheidung zuerst
mal nicht Entscheidung
also wir können diese Logik von Herrn
historius nicht wirklich nachvollziehen
denn was heißt jetzt prüfen lassen was
heißt jetzt abwägen man hätte das Ende
Februar oder im März vielleicht noch
immer Bremen tun können oder hätte
längst tun müssen heute haben wir den
331 Tag dieses Krieges und äh wir wissen
gar nicht also was soll da noch und klar
sein also für die Kollegen auch für den
neuen
Verteidigungsminister und deswegen ist
es sehr schade dass wir jetzt wieder
Zeit verlieren werden
nach wie vor dass diese Prüfung jetzt
positiv verläuft aber ich kann schon
heute denn während
wie viele Panzer einsatzbereit sind in
der Bundeswehr auch in der Industrie das
haben wir seit Monaten seit vielen
Monaten mitgeteilt und darum gebeten und
deswegen es muss endlich eine politische
Entscheidung in Berlin getroffen werden
es ist schade dass die Bundesregierung
sich bloß stellt auch in Augen unserer
Partner auf allem was die Ukraine
betrifft denn dieser Panzer werden
dringend benötigt auf dem Schlachtfeld
und die Russen zu verdrängen wir haben
gerade gehört dass den Russen die Puste
ausgeht wir müssen die diesen äh diese
diese Zeit diese Wendepunkte nutzen um
wirklich zuzuschlagen und sehr schnell
neue Gebiete zu befreien Menschen zu
befreien aus diesem russischen und was
sie haben wir haben wieder prüfen lassen
warten schauen wissen nicht was konnte
das ist natürlich sehr enttäuschen
jetzt hat ja aber Herr Pistorius gerade
in diesem Statement auch die Lieferung
eines weiteren ihres T-Systems
angekündigt und noch sieben weitere
Gepard Panzer hilft das nicht
doch also wir sind dankbar für jede
Hilfe die heute vor allem im Rahmen von
diesem Rammstein treffen verkündet wurde
sie wissen dass die Amerikaner das
größte Hilfspaket heute
zugesagt haben 2,3 Milliarden Euro und
aber auch viele andere Staaten also die
neutralen Staaten wie Schweden oder
Finnland haben also historische
Entscheidungen getroffen und waren in
Höhe von Hunderten von Millionen Euro
gebilligt ein jedes System ist der
entscheidend für uns aber das ist
sozusagen noch Zukunftsmusik ich kenne
das Unternehmen sehr gute wir haben
eingefädelt dass die erste das erste
System geliefert wurde das was da
könntet wurde wird nicht früher als ähm
Ende des Jahres vielleicht im kommenden
Jahr sogar ankommen und Leopard-Panzer
ist das was nicht nur die Deutschen und
zwar sie uns liefern können sondern auch
viele anderen Staaten die Polen wir
Finnland wir Spanien es sind dutzende
Staaten die über diese Leopard 2 Panzer
verfügen und darum geht es es geht eben
um die Schnelligkeit es geht um den
Moment um die Verluste unsere Armee zu
verringern um das Leben der Zivilisten
zu schonen das ist das entscheidende
man konnte dem Statement von pistorias
jetzt gerade auch entnehmen dass er
eigentlich sagt diese öffentliche
Wahrnehmung von einer meinungskoalition
gegen Deutschland die sei in der
Realität eigentlich gar nicht vorhanden
es gäbe durchaus Bündnispartner die
einen für und wieder von solchen
Kampfpanzern noch abwägen wie erklären
Sie sich das
schauen Sie also ich es ist schwer dass
zu kommentieren also diese Sichtweise
denn
was auf dem Spiel steht aus unserer
Sicht ist eben diese
führungskraftführungsrolle zu spielen ja
und es geht ja nicht darum dass man sich
irgendwie versteckte und abwartet oder
was andere
kleinere Staaten tun und erst dann zu
agieren es geht darum dass Deutschland
jetzt das größte das wichtigste Land in
Europa ist und bleiben wird und für
viele Staaten schauen gerade nach Berlin
und sie und sie orientieren sich nachdem
was die Bundesregierung tut oder halt
nicht tut und deswegen ist es so bitte
und unter deutschen dass man immer
wieder schaut
und die werden weiterhin lassen es geht
darum dass das machen natürlich jetzt
auch nicht das Gesicht verliert ich kann
verstehen aus taktischen Gründen dass
Pistorius nicht den Eindruck erwecken
lassen möchte dass er jetzt unter Druck
agiert und ich möchte hoffen ehrlich ich
möchte hoffen dass dass dieser Vertagung
eine Entscheidung nur damit verbunden
ist dass man jetzt ein bisschen ein paar
Tage sich nimmt und dann sagt ja wir
wollen das tun wir wollen grünes Licht
geben für die Lieferungen von anderen
Partnern für Leopard 2 Panzer und die
möchten das ist unsere große Hoffnung
wir möchten auch selbst einen Beitrag
dazu leisten und das liefern was möglich
ist und Sie haben gesehen die
Niederlande also die haben oder die
Ideen haben alle ähm
der französische Herstellung
gekauft in Frankreich und sie haben
heute oder gestern noch beschlossen
zentrale ihre Haube zum anbie Ukraine zu
übergeben jetzt sind sie sie haben gar
nichts mehr aber das ist die
Entscheidung das ist quasi das ist
Investment aus ihrer Sicht in die
Sicherheit des Landes selbst und der
Senator Allianz und darum geht es es
geht darum dass man aufhört immer wieder
zu zögern abzuwickeln sondern wirklich
das mutige Handeln ist das was nicht
noch aus unserer Sicht benötigt wird
sondern auch die Partner die vielen
Partner erwarten das von Deutschland
jetzt ist ja eine Sorge die öffentlich
immer wieder besprochen wurde oder einen
Grund nicht zu liefern dass man sagt gut
in so einem Bündnis da hat man eben auch
die Bündnis Verantwortung und wenn man
jetzt Kampfpanzer liefern würde dann
würden da am Ende neben einigen wenigen
britischen Kampfpanzern vor allem Panzer
aus deutscher Produktion stehen und das
müsste ja in einem Bündnis klar
abgestimmt werden die USA liefert bisher
keine Kampfpanzer auch die Franzosen
sind sagen wir mal zögern das noch raus
oder sind sich unsicher können Sie diese
bündnissage die immer wieder
angesprochen wird verstehen
natürlich können wir diese Sorge
nachvollziehen aber wir haben auch etwas
anderes im Blick nämlich
es wird ja nicht erwartet dass die
Deutschen alle ihre Panzer oder sogar
die Hälfte oder sogar in dritte sondern
es würde genügen dass die Deutschen
vielleicht 10% von dem angeben was sie
haben die anderen Staaten also die
Griechenland
die würden auch ihren Beitrag leisten
und nur indem jedes Land ein ein kleines
Stück sei sagen wir 10% von dem abgibt
was man hat in den bestehenden der
Streitkräfte haben wir innerhalb von
wenigen Wochen eine ganze Armee von
mindestens 200 oder sogar mehr Leopard
fahren soll und darum geht es natürlich
die Franzosen aus Paris dass sie ihre
Erklärung
Kampfpanzer liefern könnten und
natürlich sollte das alles abgestimmt
werden innerhalb
wie gesagt es ist nicht so dass wir
jetzt unsere Partner irgendwie über
strapazieren wollen nein das ist die
Entscheidung der deutschen eine
souveränen Entscheidung aber wir hoffen
wir hoffen dass im Blick vor allem die
Nöte und das Leiden der Menschen in die
Ukraine sein sollte und auch die der
Wunsch unsere Armee massiv zu stärken
und das Momentum zu nutzen um die Russen
zu verdrängen
manche sprechen aktuell auch von so
einer Art Poker der irgendwie im
Hintergrund weitergeht um diese
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern haben Sie
denn die Hoffnung dass Amerikaner Briten
Franzosen und Deutsche am Ende jetzt
doch noch gemeinsam liefern
ja wissen sie das ist das Letzte was wir
brauchen nämlich irgendwelche
Wettbewerbe oder Konkurrenz zwischen den
Partner
aber nicht also für uns steht alles auf
dem Spiel es geht um das Überlebende
Ukraine nach wie vor sind zwar da wir
kämpfen wir konnten gewisse Teile der
der besetzten Gebiete zurück erobern
aber Putin stellt sich ein auf ein sehr
sehr langen Brief das sehen wir er
stoppt die Produktion auf er bereitet
sich darauf dass sie richtig Geduld im
Westen und zu helfen irgendwann zu Ende
ist und das muss man das muss man
verhindern deswegen es geht nicht um die
Konkurrenz es geht darum dass man das
alles koordiniert hoffentlich viel
besser als als bis heute das auch hier
Amerikaner natürliche Entscheidung
treffen nicht nur jetzt Schützenbahn
verbreiten oder Striker dass das heute
verkündet wurde zu liefern sondern auch
die Abrahams Panzer dafür gibt es groß
und Kontrast aber das einzige Modell von
Kampfpanzer westliche Bauart das Ideal
wäre für die Ukraine das sind halt jeder
operaten und da spielen die deutschen
Eingewöhnung
ich habe aus unserer Community noch eine
Frage die direkt an sie geht und zwar
fragt Roman Romanowski auf Youtube was
für Waffen will denn die Ukraine ganz
konkret von uns haben können Sie das für
unsere Zuschauer und Zuschauerin noch
mal zusammenfassen
auf jeden Fall sehr cool ich versuche
mich kurz zu halten also einerseits
brauchen wir diese
diese neue Feuerkraft und auch dem
schlagfeld und das sind vor allem jetzt
nicht nur die schützenpanzerade die dazu
gesagt wurden aber wir wissen noch nicht
welche Stückzahlen das heißt das muss
jetzt sehr zügig kommen Leopard Panzer
das ist quasi die nächste Entscheidung
dann bräuchten wir Batterie das sind die
panzerhaufen das was die Deutschen uns
geliefert haben dafür sind wir sehr
dankbar das war ja noch im Sommer aber
wir brauchen viel mehr solche Systeme
weil die entscheidet den Krieg wir
brauchen natürlich ihre Idee und
deswegen danke dafür dass diese neue
Zusage kam aber aber auch die
Stückzahlen muss erhöht werden es geht
um die Produktion da gibt es
Beschränkungen bei der Produktion und
das entscheidende wird sein wir brauchen
nicht nur eine Pflanze Allianz
Fall von unseren Partner sondern auch
wir bräuchten auch
Kampfflugzeuge wir brauchen Kampfjets
und auch da denken wir darüber nach dass
eine Koalition der Willigen gebildet
werden kann mit den amerikanischen F16
Systemen vielleicht mit dem deutschen
Tornados auch mit Eurofighters mit
anderen Flugzeugen die auch schnell
lieferbar wären und die auch nicht die
Deutschen sprechen würde und wir
brauchen auch für die Marine das stand
bis heute gar nicht auf der Tagesordnung
wir brauchen auch
Kriegsschiffe U-Boote die die Deutschen
auch produzieren ich war selbst da in
Kiel und in Eckernförde ich habe gesehen
das würde auch uns massiv helfen die
Küste zu schützen vor dem Angriffen aus
der Krems aus dem Süden und wir brauchen
Munition auch das ist ein ein
Flaschenhals Munition wird sehr sehr
schnell aufgebraucht und deswegen auch
da müssen
Produktionsketten schon heute in Auftrag
gegeben werden aufgebaut werden damit
der Mitte wir da diesen Kampf solange
führen können wie das der Kanzler sagt
bis es nötig ist um alle Gebiete zu
befreien
Herr Melnik abschließend noch eine Frage
aus der Community an sie und zwar fragt
auf Youtube jemand hallo Herr Melnik was
empfehlen Sie der deutschen Bevölkerung
welche die Position von Olaf Scholz also
wahrscheinlich dieses Zögern gerade
nicht teilt
also ich glaube man man sollte auch
buchstäbliche Flagge zeigen
es gibt Möglichkeiten mal vielleicht zu
demonstrieren vor dem pflanzenamt mal
Briefe zu schreiben
sicher auch sonst so engagieren auf die
Straßen zu gehen und zu sagen ja also
die Öffentlichkeit ist gezahlt das ist
klar wie in jeder demokratischen
Gesellschaft da können wir verstehen
aber man muss auch vor Augen führen
worum es geht es geht ja nicht nur um
irgend welchen Grenzkonflikt zwischen
zwei Nachbarstaaten irgendwo am Ende der
Welt es geht um ein und den größten
Krieg mitten in Europa vor der Haustür
der deutschen und dass diese kriegt auch
die deutschen betrifft und zwar im
Inneren im Herzen weil auch Interessen
der deutschen betroffen sind die
Sicherheit der Bundesrepublik und ich
möchte nur diese Menschen ja vielleicht
dazu mal motivieren und anspornen weil
auch physische Frage zu zeigen diese
Körperlichkeit ist nicht etwas was was
wir wünschen wir möchten denn ukrainen
unseren Freunden unsere Nachbarn wir
sind ja alle Europäer helfen mit allem
was wir haben und darum geht es heute
Dankeschön Herr mening ich habe hier zum
Schluss noch eine Stimme aus der
Community die ich gerne mit Ihnen teilen
möchte und zwar sagt Ivan bikovic uns
auf Youtube die ukraine:innen wollen die
Panzer damit sie für ihre Freiheit
selbst kämpfen können ich hoffe dass wir
sie liefern Herr menik ich danke Ihnen
ganz herzlich für das Gespräch und
schicke Ihnen alles Gute nach Kiew alles
gut
ja das war unser ZDF heute live zum
Zwischenstand in Ramstein Deutschland
wird vorerst keine Kampfpanzer liefern
ob es die nächsten Tage noch eine
Entscheidung gibt oder ob das ganze noch
Wochen dauert wir bleiben auf jeden Fall
für euch dran danke für eure Fragen und
Kommentare hier bei ZDF heute live und
wenn ihr mögt bis nächstes Mal
[Musik]